Devon let's take the hypothetical budget
of a million dollars let's say you have
a writer-director that says that's what
they have
what is your litmus test to make sure
that that's exactly what will fall under
that amount what are you doing what are
you testing to make sure the poker Wow
once I read the script that say somebody
nella budget I'll read the script and
first I'll look at how many locations
two are how many actors there are and
there's any stunts that's the first
three things I look at and then based
off that I will go through and again it
also how many pages of the script
because if it's you know if it's a 90
page script then we know we're gonna
shoot for three weeks are we gonna shoot
for four weeks if it's 120 pages are we
gonna shoot for five weeks or six weeks
so that extends the budget you know so
based on the number of pages that's that
has a lot to do with it also so after I
do all that then what's like first I'll
go okay we can shoot this in say four
weeks and then I go this is what the
crew that I'm gonna they're not plugging
all the crew that were I know it's
necessary that we're gonna need to have
for the type of film that it is once I
get the crew all done then I go back and
do the cast and go that way because once
I have the hard numbers in for all the
crew that's just we're gonna need those
guys there's no negotiation we need
those guys enough enough how much for
catering and how much for crafty you
know that and then we're left with do
the locations and then do they do the
actors and which I have all the hard
cost in go back and go you get this much
to pay actors you got this much for
locations what do you want to do you
know you won't put more money towards
actors and less towards locations but
again you have to allocate enough money
to two locations and make sure you can
get them and they you know then you got
a there's always like a 10% contingency
in the budget that we allocate and then
you guys factor in post-production
what's the post-production being done
all in-house and you're not going to
include that in the budget production
budget but the same thing because the
budgets that we I normally do I'm sure
it's the same for line producers they're
just constant there ever-changing so all
have a budget and allocate
certain amount of money and always kind
of overcompensate in the beginning
because then we I know once I start
negotiating rates or whatnot can start
pitting in real numbers the budget
always seems to the numbers instead the
money is the same is just the money is
just moving around so I find up saving
$5,000 on locations that $5,000 just
gonna go towards something else that
he's more that's gonna need more money
so it's kind of looks like a little
little puzzle is constantly shifting as
we go through the production
you